are you ingesting large amount of data
for analysis or looking to simplify the
development of event-driven applications
then stay tuned to learn more about
Cloud fossa
[Music]
in the last episode we looked at cat
outs asynchronous order processing
service with and without cloud pub/sub
we also learned how cloud pub/sub is
perfect for such use cases to scale
seamlessly for millions of messages
today we will consider our cat out
example again which is a simple case of
a workflow application implemented as a
set of services connected asynchronously
by messages we will also see how cloud
pub/sub helps cat out expand their
application globally as the name pops up
indicates cloud pub/sub supports a
publisher subscriber model a publisher
application creates and sends messages
to a topic which is a named resource and
the messages are stored until
acknowledged by all subscribers to
receive these messages a subscriber
application creates a subscription to a
topic the subscriber receives a message
by either cloud pub/sub pushing them to
the subscribers chosen endpoint or by
subscriber pulling them from the service
when a message is acknowledged by the
subscriber it is removed from the
subscription backlog and not delivered
again the message itself can contain the
payload and optional attributes that
describes the payload content
communication can be one-to-many also
called fan-out many-to-one
or fan-in and many-to-many which means
if subscriber x wants to receive
messages from two different publishers e
and b it can be achieved by creating two
subscriptions corresponding to the
topics for each publisher which is a
many to one model
similarly if two different applications
want to subscribe to the same message
from a publisher then it can be achieved
by creating two different subscriptions
from the same topic which is a
one-to-many model
now remember cat out the order
processing and delivery service from the
last episode let's see how pub subtopic
and subscriptions would be set up for
this asynchronous functionality the
order service sends the messages to pub
subtopic where they get stored the
packaging and notification service
stripe to these messages through the
respective pub/sub subscription in a
fan-out fashion packaging service will
send messages to pub subtopic and the
shipping and notification service will
subscribe to the respective pub sub
subscription
similarly the shipping service will send
the messages to pub sub topic and the
order and notification service will
subscribe to the respective parts of
subscriptions now Kat out is going
through a global expansion with
packaging service in Europe and order
processing service in us because cloud
pops up is a global service it ensures
that messages get from one location to
another no matter where these services
are with consistent latency and no
replication necessary this is huge for
the cat out team because they can focus
on developing the service and leave the
global scaling to cloud pop so what do
we need to know about publisher and
subscriber endpoints well let's see
publishers can be any application that
can make HTTP requests to Google API is
calm an app engine app a web service
hosted on Google compute engine or any
other third-party network an installed
app for desktop or mobile devices or
even a browser pull subscribers can also
be any application that can make HTTP
requests to Google API is calm although
push subscribers must be web hook
endpoints that can accept post requests
over HTTP cloud pub/sub is all about
service integration data is ingested
into cloud pub/sub from the front end
services databases and other event
producers then received by cloud
dataflow or our other event processing
service for deduplication or during an
enrichment from cloud dataflow the event
can be sent to multiple targets it can
be used to facilitate and user
experiences like managing notification
via firebase notifications and messaging
or storing and user state in pharr store
or managing an IOT device other targets
could be data warehouse or data leaks
like bigquery and GCS or event-driven
and service apps like cloud functions
App Engine and cloud
big table could also be a target for
operational databases or just gaseous
cloud pub/sub
has lots of different use cases which
can be categorized into two broad
buckets it's great for streaming
analytics or ingestion of data into
analytical systems it's also great for
implementing asynchronous workflows like
the order processing application we saw
earlier in the cat out example let us
know how you use cloud pub/sub in your
environments in the comments below
alright so today we learn what is cloud
pub/sub how it works and some of the
most common use cases join us next time
to dive deeper and actually build a
cloud pub/sub system from scratch if you
liked this video and would like to see
more such content don't forget to Like
and subscribe to our Channel